joe biden who does this all on a stage
which is very weird
he got his fourth shot
yeah take a look so now i'm gonna get my
second booster shot
[Applause]
i'm reluctant to comment
can you comment on the declassified
intelligence that he doesn't trust his
military leadership since it is
declassified
provide security now to ukraine as part
of peace talks you agree
is
is the u.s willing to provide security
guarantees to ukraine as part of peace
talks or russia
mr president are you going to extend
title 42
what did president
tell you about between
four countries on vaccination will
impact your uh the fight against coped
here
what a present is
i've always thought that it discourages
people getting the vaccination when they
watch people get a needle in their arm
so uh i apologize by discouraging him it
didn't hurt a bit and i was able to roll
my sleeve up and thank you all
[Music]
i feel very confident of everything
happening in this country when i listen
to that man and i watch whatever that
theater
show was that was a theater first off he
is on a stage do you know that that is a
sound stage with lights like i have in
this studio it's a studio he even says
why am i doing this in a studio
basically in front of people
[Applause]
he doesn't know what he's doing he's
obviously not in charge they're
injecting the man right in front of us
it's like i think that was pretty much
the plot of the gi joe movie where
they're injecting the president with
something it's like what the high hell
is going on here
is i mean really really like am i being
over the top here but is anyone watching
that and feeling confident about any of
this so that was his second booster shot
which is why i said it was his fourth
shot because you get the shot then you
get the booster you get the shot and
then you get the booster so they're just
injecting the president with stuff why
the woman next to him is wearing a mask
i don't know why is she wearing a mask
right she's obviously waxed and boosted
and everything else and let's not forget
only a few weeks ago he was with all the
other geriatric people at the state of
the union and they were rubbing heads
and sniffing hair and everything else